news daily from science mission authors
in the journal Cell report that neuronal
activity leads to double-stranded DNA
breaks in the promoter region of the
early response gene and topoisomerase is
required for this process activity
induce double-stranded breaks facilitate
enhancer promoter interaction and
expression of early response genes in
neuron next pathway involved in the
immune response to HIV infection has
been previously described now
researchers identify a protein called PQ
BP one has another component of the
pathway that directly binds to HIV and
interacts with the sea gas to regulate
host response next diurnal variation in
the secretion of bile acids that control
absorption of nutrients was attributed
to the variation the 67 a one enzyme
authors in the journal Nature
communications provide evidence for the
existence of a new pathway showing that
diurnal expression of transcription
factor klf 15 regulates FG of 15
secretion from the enterocyte which then
inhibits bile acid synthesis in the
liver for more news visitors at www
science mission calm or science mission
facebook page thanks for watching